the Coast Guard is the only military
branch that does not get paid during the
shutdown because it's part of the
Department of Homeland Security one
Coast Guard support groups advice for
affected families hold a garage sale its
five-page financial guide for Coast
Guard families listed ways to supplement
their income they included not just a
garage sale but also babysitting and
tutoring students the advice was later
removed from the support website the
spokesman says the information in this
document does not reflect the Coast
Guard's current efforts to support its
workforce during this lapse Janet
shamlian spoke to three Coast Guard
wives in Bay Cliff Texas at southeast of
Houston they shared their struggles of
not knowing when their husbands will get
their money what type of changes are you
making in your household right now to
account for the fact that you may not be
getting a paycheck well our budget is
extremely tight we have just bought only
the necessities when we went grocery
shopping and you know trying to you know
look at the sales and see what's on sale
does anybody are you cooking or are you
changing how you utilizing and struggle
meals they call them you know was a
struggle meal you take whatever's in the
fridge and whatever's in the pantry and
throw it in a casserole and that's a
meal your target room never get run
can't even shop in that little dollar
section that everybody gets hung up we
just want there to be a resolution that
puts the Coast Guard and in a situation
to actually be respected and treated the
way that they should be as far as
funding goes you feel like because
they're not getting paid and the other
branches of the military are that
they're oh they're absolutely being
overlooked we're at pawns
they're just playing with us you know
we've discussed should I get a second
job but unfortunately I can't because he
can't be in daycare with his health
issues so for us it's that one paycheck
no matter what knowing that at any given
moment he sorry
she could have open-heart surgery so how
are we gonna pay for that gas to get us
to the Medical Center
if that happens for him so what paycheck
should it be what we're worrying about
when he should be my focus is it hard to
sit here and talk to me about how tight
money is bears and bears yeah it's a lot
of different emotions at one time on top
of everything we personally have going
on home we've had a really rough couple
of days
so build the wall don't build a wall but
pare husband's well it shouldn't be
embarrassing for them it's embarrassing
for the country as a whole that families
like that whose spouses served the
country have to have struggle meals
because of a crisis like yeah and it's I
still keep thinking the people that are
making these decisions are getting paid
while these other people are just living
day to day paycheck to paycheck it's
it's not right it was extraordinary
figure I saw yesterday 80% of the
country lives paycheck to pay and and
and then we're seeing it right there
during a healthy economy right at that